aux états unis il est assez clairement
établi que les média choisi cinq ans
lors d'une élection présidentielle
parfois les organes de presse affichent
clairement leurs intentions comme il ya
quelques semaines lorsque le washington
post
propriété du milliardaire jeff bezos ce
publie un éditorial appelant à battre
donald trump qualifié de pire président
des temps modernes
parmi les illustrations concrètes de ce
deux poids deux mesures tel qu'il est
ressenti par les supporters de donald
trump
il y à l'histoire de hunter baden le
fils d'un ancien vice président des
états unis accusé d'avoir utilisé la
position de son père pour faire des
affaires
le tout sur fond de soupçons de liens
avec la chine et l'ukraine l'histoire
koch un certain nombre de cases pour
faire les gros titres et pourtant
lorsque le new york post révèle ce qui
pourrait être le contenu d'un ordinateur
portable ayant appartenu à hunter biden
l'afer est censurée par twitter et
facebook et ne trouve quasiment aucune
reprise dans les médias traditionnels
il aura fallu finalement attendre
plusieurs jours pour que joe biden ne
soient interrogés sur cette affaire
j'ai mise en oeuvre la politique
américaine pas une seule chose n'était
hors des clous pas une seule chose
premièrement deuxièmement le type qui a
eu des hauts revenus en ukraine était ce
type qui essayait de coraux pour le
gouvernement ukrainien pour qu'il dise
quelque chose de négatif à mon sujet ce
qu'il ne ferait pas et n'a pas fait
parce que cela ne s'est jamais produit
monfils n'a pas gagné d'argent grâce à
ce qu'il dit de la chine
je n'ai pas eu le seul gars qui a gagné
de l'argent en chine et ce gars là
et en ce qui concerne la télévision ce
n'est guère différent la plupart des
network américain sont très critiques à
l'égard de donald trump à l'exception de
fox news détenu par rupert murdoch qui
détient également le new york post et
qui fait campagne pour le candidat
républicain donald trump a souvent en
dénoncer cette différence de traitement
encore tout récemment lorsqu'il a quitté
précipitamment une interview avec le
programme sixty minutes votre première
intervention et et ça va être des
questions difficiles ça ne me gêne pas
mais quand vous avez organisé l'entrevue
vous n'aviez pas dit ça vous aviez dit
haut ce sera une belle interview
j'ai vu votre entrevue avec joe biden
c'était une blague
l interview de 60 minutes j'ai vu un joe
biden on lui fait cadeau sur cadeaux
j'ai vu toutes ses interviews
on ne lui posent jamais les questions
difficiles je pense qu'on en a terminé
avec cette interview ok ça suffit on y
va il faut dire que donald trump a
souvent entretenu des relations
délicates avec les médias n'hésitant pas
parfois à faire huer la tribune de
presse lors de certains de ses meetings
par une salle chauffée à blanc c'est
dans ce contexte particulier que se
déroule donc cette élection américaine
nous avons interrogé les new yorkais sur
le traitement médiatique qui a été
réservé aux deux candidats
je crois que les médias les chaînes
neutre essaye d'être équilibrés mais si
vous regardez fox news ils ne sont pas
dans cet équilibre
ms nbc non plus il penche d'un seul côté
de la balance
personnellement je pense que les médias
ont donnée trop d'attention à trump ces
cinq dernières années
ce à quoi vous donner de l'attention
grossi forcément le problème c'est que
peu importe de quel côté vous êtes vous
avez des médias que vous préférez lire
regarder c'est de notre faute si vous
êtes progressiste si vous êtes démocrate
vous regardez probablement cnn ou ms nbc
où vous écouter la radio publique
nationale et si vous supportez trump
vous regardez certainement foxnews très
régulièrement chahuté par le président
la plupart des médias américains ont
donc décidé de faire le jeu de joe biden
faisant preuve de mansuétude à son égard
tout en étant très critique contre
donald trump un positionnement à double
tranchant à une époque où les
journalistes n'ont plus vraiment bonne
presse aux yeux de millions de citoyens
cette stratégie pourrait se retourner
contre les médias et galvanisé
l'électorat populaire de donald trump